you guys sure you want to do this let's
play No hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to genital
jousting here's a big flashy warning
there's penises and Dickson butts
alright but we don't need to do online
we got our friends right here and so
while we're playing this we're gonna
imagine this is thank you
damn it right now you say this is
planning for later tonight
no I'm saying we're well experienced in
this game because a CG waggle and the
knell waggles away we're gonna try we've
never played this wait has never even
seen it no well there goes the concern
of the consent
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's uh let's see this new costume that
we have for you if I get the first I
know
[Applause]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
well maybe we can save that for the next
episode because anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching anyway so
thanks for watching obviously this video
is age restricted so congrats for being
the right age but either way if you want
to see more of this let us know down in
the comments below if you're horribly
affected by this let us know down in the
comments below if you never want to see
this ever again
let us know in the comments below if
you've giggled even a little bit
sure so let us know what I have to
comment below thanks again everybody for
watching check out their links to the
description and as always see you in the
next video
[Music]